esta es la maqueta monumental que recrea
el templo mayor mexica aquí en el
epicentro de lo que fuera la gran
tenochtitlán de esta maqueta de 16
metros está acompañada de un espectáculo
de luces y de vídeo mapping que recrea
la historia de las vibraciones de la
gran tenochtitlán justo ahora que se
conmemoran los 500 años de la caída de
la urbe en mesitas 500 años de la
conquista española como lo prefiere
llamar el gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador 500 años de resistencia
indígena
estará disponible para el público hasta
el 1 de septiembre y forma parte de
todas estas su mejor acción es si se han
dado cita a cientos de capitalinos y a
pesar de estar en la tercera ola de la
pandemia de cómic 19 algunos han
criticado esta maqueta también
especialistas han cuestionado su
utilidad
al encontrarse a un lado del verdadero
templo mayor pero algunos otros
ciudadanos han aplaudido y vitoreado
este espectáculo y esta memoria a
quinientos años de la caída de pelos y
planos